welcome everyone
brothers and sisters assalamu alaikum
respected guests thank you for joining
us
on our latest installment of zadil mahad
fi hadi hair lay bad
we now are going to transition into
the way that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would pray
and there are two
introductions or two i will preface this
with two
two things number one
as we kind of alluded to in our last
lecture
this is an issue which there is a lot of
difference of opinion with regards to
the details
however the main principles and outline
and structure of salah and all of the
other warships and laws of islam
for that matter are something which are
an issue of consensus amongst the
scholarship of islam
alhamdulillah and that is part of the
preservation of allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
of this great book of this
great book the quran and the sunna of
the messenger muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam at the hands of very
very profound scholars
the second thing i want to mention is
that
the information that you're about to
hear
some people may find that you know it's
not as lively it's not as exciting it's
not as engaging
well we are learning about the prophet
sallallahu
we're learning how to stand up in front
of allah
and some of these things may be
kind of kind of
tedious to some it may come out as kind
of tedious kind of
uneventful but this is what knowledge is
knowledge is something that a person has
to be very patient with
as a matter of fact
the great scholar who has the
compilation
muslim he narrates in his introduction
[Arabic recitation]
was
one of the scholars of the companions
he said
he says tell the seeker of knowledge
to prepare himself
with two shoes of iron
why what he's trying to say is that the
the road of knowledge is tedious
and it doesn't really all fit together
at the beginning
you have to give it time this is how
knowledge
forms in the mind you we don't take in
knowledge all at once
it doesn't download into our minds and
we suddenly know
no that's not how the human mind works
the human mind has been designed in a
very profound way
that the person's soul grows
gradually with the knowledge that he or
she learns
right this is what knowledge is about
but that path is is a tedious path and
it takes discipline
and a person has to have a passion
to learn how do you learn this well
you need to have a good intention and
you need to feel in your heart of hearts
by learning oh allah i need to learn i
need to know
how to stand in front of you i need to
know
how to prepare myself to meet you
this is something that has to be learned
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said
he says knowledge is only achieved by
seeking it and forbearance and patience
is only achieved by practice
this is how it works and so
this this is real knowledge i mean we
could speak all day about inspirational
quotes and that has its place
but that's not where our
focus should always be our focus should
always be on
how do i learn to please allah that's
what all this is about
now goes into
how did he pray he says
when he wished to stand to pray
[Arabic recitation]
akbar
he would not say anything prior to
[Arabic recitation]
before there is no
introduction there is no preface
nor would he ever pronounce audibly his
intention nor did any of the taberine
none of the earlier generations of islam
ever pronounce audibly
their intentions
nor any of the four scholars of the form
of
so let's unpack that a little bit when a
person wishes to pray
he will stand face the qibla and say
[Arabic recitation]
that's it there is no no
there is no i intend to pray such and
such you know when we were kids
growing up the way we were taught to
pray is
something along the lines of no way
so we would have this long spiel that we
would we would give
i have intended now to pray
for for sale for instance
facing the qibla
with the intention of that this is an
obligate obligatory prayer of
and if there's imam we would say behind
this imam
and so on and so forth and we would give
all these details
everything except for our address and
phone number
and that is not correct there is no
evidence of this that the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
ever did this not before not before
salah
not before fasting or zakah or any of
the
other worship there's only one instance
and that is when a person begins
his hajj or umrah and that's not really
a pronunciation
of one's it's not really a proclamation
of one's intention
as much as it is an initiation
just we start our salah with allah
we start our hajj with
and so that is the first thing
many people they feel kind of they don't
want to
differ with this they don't they want
they don't want to leave it off they say
okay i understand that the prophet
salallahu didn't do it but what's the
harm
right what's the harm
i will mention two things
number one is
i will prove to you that all that
statement
of pronouncing our intentions prior to
prayer
actually to us equals zero and i'll show
you how
let's say a person stands to make salah
and in giving their pronouncing or
proclaiming their intention they say
no
so they slip they misspeak instead of
saying
they say and then they start to pray
they meant us but they said
they misspoke is that prayer valid or
invalid
well definitely it is valid
and that is an issue of consensus
amongst the scholars of islam
why because the time
and intention in the heart
meaning the circumstances the context
under under which that was said
and my intention in my heart
that takes precedence over my
misspeaking
right if that is the case then what's
the point of saying your nia
what's what's the point of it if you say
it right or wrong
the salah is unaffected so why would we
need to say this
right second of all
a person may say i know listen to the
statement i know
however what's the harm okay
imagine with me
that every muslim from the time of the
prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam till
today
had that attitude and
each muslim had
one thing of islam that they took away
or added under the guise of what's the
harm
right this is what we call innovation in
islam
so imagine if every muslim had just they
added one little thing to islam or they
took away one little thing
do that for 1500 years do that with
billions of people
what of islam would be left by now
the answer is not very much if anything
it's mentioned that one-fourth of the
original
torah has been changed and altered
in its wording and that is something
that
jewish scholars
admit to right and concede
that yes this has been changed it's not
what musa alayhis-salam originally
brought
could you imagine this book is all we
have
this is the only thing we have and so we
have to make sure that it is purified
day in and day out and that we
never add or take away anything
not in our actions not in our statements
and certainly
that we don't teach others to carry on
such a legacy
if i can add whatever i want and take
off whatever i want because i
see that it's okay well
that's kind of an invalidation of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam's
legacy isn't it
did he go through all of what he went
through
did he spend all of those years
trying to articulate to us the message
of our lord
only for me to now
change it as i and do with it what
i want that's not acceptable
and so this is how the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam would stand
to pray
another statement ibn al-qaeda makes
which is very interesting
he says none of the four imams of the
form of
have adopted this opinion that a person
should verbalize
his or her intention and that is true
and when someone ibn kayem
says none of the four imams have
have endorsed that or adopted that
or encouraged that you can go ahead and
as we say in america
you can take that to the bank you can
count on that
right that is solid because you are
hearing this from an imam
who has mastered the form of someone who
is considered
a reference of
islamic doctrine and law
for everyone who has can come after him
he says
he says and the way that the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam would
initiate his prayer
[Arabic recitation]
and he would never say anything else to
initiate his prayer
this first takbir this initial takbir
which is referred to by the scholars of
phil
as taqbir
this is a pillar of prayer
this is something that is a pillar if
[Arabic recitation]
initiate your prayer
you have not even begun praying yet
[Arabic recitation]
initiate his prayer
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would simultaneously
raise both of his hands
with the fingers of his hands extended
so not this
he would extend his fingers this
and he would face the qibla
with his hands palms towards the qibla
right so not this
i've even heard this which you know i
i still today have not found where that
came from
and what people do and basically what
people do you can never
completely know all of what they do
however he would raise his hands
with the palms facing towards the qibla
with the fingers extended right
they would not be spread open they would
not be clasped
close the hands are extended towards the
qibla
he says
this is the furor of the udon right
the earlobes that he would raise his
hands to
ear level just i'm doing right now
and it's also been narrated to shoulder
level
so he would sometimes raise his hands
this sometimes he would raise his
hands this
shoulder level right it's interesting
people who wish to do the sunnah
that sometimes people get lazy and they
end up neither doing the sunnah nor
not doing the sunnah they start doing
other things so you'll see people that
pray they
they'll raise their hands this
they want to do i've even seen this just
this
that is not the sun of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
you're better off not doing that at all
because that now has nothing to do with
saleh
if you are going to raise your hands you
raise your hands shoulder height
or you raise your hands ear height this
is how the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
would initiate his prayer he says
and he would then place his right hand
over his left hand interesting point
here
mentions that the right over the left
right and this goes back to a narration
in which the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
said
he said we the prophets have been
commanded
that in prayer we are to place our right
hands
over our left hands he says
and that we also break our fast as soon
as the sun goes down at the earliest
time that is
permissible so
right hand on the left that's something
that has been agreed upon amongst the
scholars of islam
the authentic narrations of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam are
he would place his right over his left
right now other narrations have been
narrated
some say under his navel some say on his
navel
some say above his navel some say on his
chest
and i'll tell you now all of the
narrations
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam with regards to
where he would place his hands are weak
narrations
the scholars then differ on what is best
should we use a weak narration should we
go with the least weak
should we they differ on how they
approach that
anatomically speaking there is a
principle that the scholars of islam
have employed
and this is a principle that imam hashem
allah as well has employed and that is
any movement or position
in prayer now focus with me this is a
principle
any movement or position in
prayer which contradicts
the natural anatomy of the human body
needs a specific evidence
what does that mean well naturally
if i'm going to place my right hand over
my left hand
and the the companions narrate
that we were commanded to place our
right palm
over our left wrist
okay if i'm going to do this and two
ways have been narrated some narrate
that he would grasp
others would narrate that he would place
both are the sunnah
if i'm going to do this the way that my
body
naturally does this is just this
between the navel and the chest
what contradicts the natural
anatomy of the human body meaning it's
uncomfortable then
would be up here or would be down here
okay this needs a particular
it needs a specific evidence because the
essence of the human body was created
for worship
and so it only goes to fit
that the way that a person expresses his
daily worship
should fit with the way that the human
body has been constructed
either way ibn khayyim doesn't mention
anything with regards to where a person
places his hands
he just says right over left and that's
very wise because
he mentions that this book is about the
sunnah
not about what the scholars of islam
have later stipulated
therefore as long as a person has his
right hand over his left hand wherever
it is
that is fine there is only one position
which is not permissible and that
is what is called a tasalob
a tasab is some people have read
narrations or they have read books
right and they'll notice that
in this book the scholar may write that
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would place his hands
on his chest right and they would read
this in
english so already we have a problem
that's been compounded and that is that
english is a translation it's it's not
really the actual work it's a reflection
of what the translator understood
so you read in english chest so they say
oh an english chest is right here
this is your chest so they'll put their
hands up here
that is not correct that's called and
that's
specifically impermissible right
rather the only place a person cannot
put his right over his left is up here
this this is called tasalub on the
on on the collar bones just below or
just on the collar bones
and as a matter of fact in surat yasin
allah subhanahu wa
has mentioned that the people of the
hellfire
will have their their hands
yoked to their athcon
right they will have their hands yoked
and ali
was asked what this will look like
right what does this look like
and imam he said radhiallahu
he said this and he showed just
this he put his two hands over
on top of his tar just this and he
said the people of the hellfire will be
chained and yoked
in this fashion that is not befitting
for a person to pray in that way
so this is the only place where a person
cannot place his hands
in prayer up here
and you see people place their hands up
here
in this very uncomfortable way and that
brings and presents a lot of problems
because if we were to consider that a
person is praying
in gemma and he has his brothers and
sisters real close to him
and shoulder to shoulder how are you
going to have shoulder to shoulder with
your elbows jutting out into the person
next to you
rather the prophet salallahu
he said the best of you in prayer al
hadith the best of you in prayer
are those who have the most malleable
most plastic shoulders the scholars of
islam mention what that means is that
when you're standing next to people you
don't
interfere with them you don't make them
uncomfortable
rather you form yourself to the form of
those next to you
and so if everybody is standing like
this it's not going to be possible to
to align the rose properly therefore
some scholars have mentioned this this
is the way that
ebil would
pray and imam ahmad ibn hambala and
other scholars of hadith
imam shepherd mentions this which i just
mentioned
and another in another method
of would be on
or below the navel all of this is
acceptable
he goes on to say well
now is going to get into what we call as
dua
these are small supplications
[Arabic recitation]
initiating his prayer the prophet
salallahu alaihi wasallam would make
these
supplications or these praises of allah
[Arabic recitation]
he would do these during regular salah
and he would do these during
his sunan and
salawat the only time a person is not to
do dua
is during the prayer of geneza there's
no evidence for doing it
in the prayer of geneza funeral prayer
so now we will just mention briefly if
you want a good book
that will tell you of these and you'd
to memorize some of these
supplications a very good book would be
muslim which is the fortress of the
muslim which is
absolutely abound in every muslim
household
so that is a very good book
he says sometimes he would initiate his
prayer with an initiating supplication
as
oh allah which translates to allah
my sins from me the distance that you
have made between the east and the west
allah
oh my lord oh allah bathe me
and purify me of my
sins with water
and ice
[Arabic recitation]
allah purify me so thoroughly from my
sin
just as a white
garment would be purified of impurities
he says
sometimes he would say i have faced my
face
towards the one who has created the
heavens and the earth
i have faced myself in a state
of total submission to allah not
associating others unto he
nor am i of those who would associate
others unto my lord.
indeed my prayer and my slaughter or
my worship as well as my life and even
my death
all belong to allah the lord of the
worlds
no partner is unto him
and this is what i have been commanded
and i am the first and foremost of the
muslims
and he goes on to mention many others i
will just mention them here
in arabic and those who wish to refer
to them
can refer to them in the book that we
have mentioned
will be
[Silence]
this is something he would say when he
would stand for prayer at night and
sometimes he would say allah
is this is a
supplication as well another that he
would mentioned
and so these are different ones and
there are others
and there are others
another one that he would very usually
open his prayer with is subhanak allah
then goes on to mention is seeking
refuge in allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
subhanahu says
if you wish to re recite the quran
then seek refuge in allah from the
cursed
shaitaan would the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam seek refuge in allah
from
shaitaan he would do it exactly as it is
mentioned in the quran
and then he would recite surah
speaks about the issue of when a person
says
is he seeking refuge in allah
at the beginning of his prayer or for
the occasion of
reciting the quran only
it's a difference of opinion amongst the
scholars the correct opinion that ibn
ibn kathy rahimahullah
has adopted is that a person would say
at the beginning of the prayer whether
he is going to recite the quran or not
so let's say i'm praying behind an imam
i'm not going to be reciting the quran i
will merely say
for the occasion of the prayer likewise
in
swala i would say
after the initiating technique then i
would say
so he would then recite surat al fatiha
now we're going to move into another
issue as far as reciting surat al-fatiha
that which translates to whoever does
not
recite surah in his salah
is incomplete incomplete incomplete
and he repeated it thrice it is a pillar
of salah he has also said
that one who does not recite surat
al-fatiha
in his prayer his prayer is not valid
he says and he used to recite
bismillah aloud
and most of the time he would not recite
bismillah allowed now this is another
big thing
which the scholars of islam have
differed upon and when the scholars of
islam
differ on these things they understand
the proportion of this differing it's
not such a huge deal
people who learn it and you know as the
saying goes
a little knowledge is dangerous people
who learn that little thing
they think now that they know and others
do not they run out into the world and
start having
arguments and heated debates about
this is right and this is wrong this is
correct and this is incorrect
and that is very very people of
knowledge do not
conduct themselves that people of
knowledge do not conduct themselves in
such a black and white world
there are certain things that we need to
take a stand on
there are certain things which this is
not
open to debate but
there are other things which we can
understand them in different ways
and that's fine we can understand them
in different ways
and as imam hashem when he was debating
with some of the students of imam malik
after he had debated with him he saw
that the man
kind of took offense or kind of took it
personally
and imam sheffie took his hand and said
we are
still brothers we can we can differ
without having to
have animosity there's no reason we
can't
differ right and so
some scholars mention you would say
bismillah rahman
rahim all the time it's part of surat
al-fatiha
anytime you recite it you recite
bismillah
other scholars say no you don't recite
it allowed ever
and then we have whatever nil claim has
mentioned here
that sometimes he would recite it aloud
but most of the time he would recite it
silently where does that come from
well when we look at all of the body of
narrations
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
and his companions
we see that
others of the companions they narrate
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would say
bismillah allowed in prayer
but then we have a narration such as the
narration of enes
which is muslim he says i prayed behind
the prophet muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam abu bakr and
never would they start their prayer with
bismillah
not before not after they would always
start their prayer with alhamdulillah
meaning audibly
but what does that mean does that mean
that anas ibn malik was
praying salah behind every single
prayer that the prophet muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam prayed
over a span of 13 years
or 14 years and then he prayed every
prayer behind alma
and every prayer behind abu bakr no
that's
that's just unimaginable but
let's say that that's the case we have a
principle
and that is not having
the absence of evidence is not evidence
of absence
what does that mean the absence of
evidence
is not evidence of absence
this is what we call in logic an
inductive
argument let's say
i have only seen white geese in my life
never seen a black goose
i can say with an amount of certainty
geese are white but does that
categorically mean that no black geese
exists
the answer is no that doesn't
categorically
mean that because that is the nature of
an inductive argument
the only way i could know that is if i
have observed
infinite amount of geese or all of the
geese that ever would be or could be
to be able to say i have seen
and there are no black geese
the scholars of islam say
that the absence of evidence is not an
evidence of absence
what that means is if we have two
companions
one narrates that i never saw the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam do
this and the other narrates
i saw him do this which one do we go
with
well obviously we go with the one who
affirms that he saw something
because the one who negates something
they're only speaking about their
experience
they're saying i've never seen it but it
doesn't mean just because you haven't
seen it it doesn't exist
there are many things that we haven't
seen that we haven't
heard but they exist nonetheless
and so the scholars of islam they tell
us
the one who affirms something they say i
saw this happen
we take their testimony ahead
and we give precedence to that than the
one who says i have not
seen such and such ever happen it's
because of that
and this happens sometimes in the sunnah
so
ana
as far as his experience goes he's never
heard them say bismillah rahman or rahim
at the beginning of
doesn't mean that it never happened just
means that he never experienced it
he once said to his companions i'm going
to pray for you
exactly as i observe the prophet
salallahu
so that means that it happened he saw it
but what we do understand from anas ibn
malik
is that the majority of the time
that never happened the great majority
very seldomly with the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam ever start
his
recitation with bismillah
rather he would begin it with
alhamdulillah
we will now conclude for today for
this evening
next week insha allah we will discuss
the way
and what the prophet sallallahu alaihi
foreign